Hey, welcome to the next to last day, day 39.
Today we're talking about taking up your cross daily.
Now, I've talked several times about the moment of surrender to the Lord, that
moment of yielding to Him, and it's very important.
But there's more beyond that. There's a life to be lived.
A preacher friend of mine named Dr.
Paul Kaufman shared this thought with me, and I wanted to pass it on to you.
He said, "The saintly John Fletcher, the theologian of Methodism, who was
handpicked by Wesley to succeed him as the leader of the movement,
has some amazing insights into scripture.
In my devotional reading this morning," Dr.
Kaufman said, "I came across the concerns of both Fletcher and Wesley,
who both warned that we don't bank too much on
the fact that we were justified or sanctified in a moment."
Wesley stated that some, quote, "Trust to what was
done in a moment and give up taking up their cross daily, and
to watching unto prayer with all perseverance."
Wow. Yeah. Reinforcing that same warning, John
Fletcher observed that, quote, "A manifestation of the spirit
last year will no more support a soul this year than air
breathed yesterday will nourish the flame of life today.
The sun which warmed us last week
must shine again this week. Old light is dead light.
A notion of old warmth is a very cold notion.
We must have fresh food daily, and though we need
not a new Christ, we need perpetually new displays
of his eternal love and power.
The Lord taught us this important lesson by making the
manna he gave Israel in the wilderness to
disappear every day,
and causing that which was not gathered fresh
to breed worms and stink."
Nevertheless, as the mysterious food kept sweet
in the golden pot in the ark,
so does the heavenly power of Christ, to whom
every true Israelite will come for new supplies of hidden manna,
for fresh manifestations of the Holy Spirit.
The truth is
that we need brand-new manifestations of God.
We need sometimes to newly commit ourselves to Him.
There is nothing in the teaching of God's word that says
we need to, after we're saved, we need to be filled with the Holy Spirit.
There's nothing in that, that precludes us from being filled again,
even filled continually. Ephesians 5:18 talks about the
ongoing filling of the Holy Spirit.
Acts two, the disciples were filled, and Acts four, they're filled
again because there were new challenges. There were new threats.
There were new persecutions. There were new difficulties.
It was a new day, and they needed new filling.
In the same kind of way,
how do we go about receiving those new fillings?
How do we go about that? And the answer is, we come back
and we renew our commitment.
There's nothing about renewing our commitment that doesn't mean that we've
sinned, or we've fallen, or we've fallen out of fellowship with Christ or
anything like that. It's just that our connection to the
vine must be continuous
because as soon as the
branch is cut off, regardless if the fruit still looks okay, the
branch is dead. Because the definition of life
is connection to the vine,
not green leaves.
So I would tell you that you have to, we must
surrender ourselves daily to Christ.
Take up our cross one more time and experience the freshness
every single day, every single week.
If it's been a while since you've experienced that freshness, you need to
ask the Lord and recommit to Him, and re-trust in Him,
and re-believe in Him to know the freshness and the
fullness of the power of the Spirit in your life
today. God bless you. Talk to you tomorrow.